when I was a kid I used to dream what it
would be like to live somewhere far away
from Hell's Kitchen but I realized the
city was a part of me it was my blood
and I would do anything to make it a
better place
good and evil sometimes the difference
between the two is a sharp line
sometimes it's a blur sometimes you have
to do things with outside of the law
we're gonna make a difference I know it
doesn't feel like it sometimes who we
are you're blind
but you see so much I hear things you
know what they call stuff like that gift
I'm gonna train you use it
[Music]
there are other ways to see
are left behind I don't see the city
anymore
there's only dark corners
I'll keep you safe Karen I have to be
the man this city needs
what are you gonna do whatever it takes
you and I have a lot in common
another man's evil does not make you
good I respect their conviction the lone
man thinks he can make a difference
this darkness is the nah I'm just trying
to make my city a better place maybe she
had an iron suit or magic hammer that
would explain why you keep getting your
asses attitude
hey youtubers is Charlie as you can see
they just posted a new daredevil trailer
mostly focusing on the king pink
character since I've already done a
breakdown of the man with no fear in the
comics the storyline they're adapting
for the TV show I'm just gonna do an
explainer for the kingpins character in
his history in the comics there was also
some new photos of David Tennant
visiting the Marvel offices that are
pretty cool that I'll explain a little
bit he's playing Kilgore in the Jessica
Jones series I know everyone's really
happy to see David Tennant joined the
Marvel Cinematic Universe and yes
daredevil all these Netflix shows for
those that are asking they're part of
the MCU the Marvel Cinematic Universe
but don't expect a lot of crossovers
with movie characters they're mostly
keeping it self-contained to the other
Netflix series so the characters that
crossover will be on those other Netflix
shows like Luke Cage Jessica Jones iron
fist and then the defenders Captain
America Civil Wars a pretty likely
candidate for crossovers though so
Wilson Fisk aka the kingpin of crime--
most of you probably know him from some
of the cartoons or maybe from the comics
I think after Frank Miller started
writing the comic book in the 1980s he
really became more of a daredevil
character and especially now after this
daredevil series that's probable are
gonna think about him he was created by
Stan Lee and John Romita senior in 1967
his first issue was amazing spider-man
number 50 Stan Lee said he wanted a
character that treated crime like it was
only a business he treats crime like
Tony Stark treats tech manufacturing
which is funny because there was
actually a time in the comics when
kingpin and Tony Stark owned a company
together it was during a comic series
called damage control he spent most of
his early run in the spider-man comics
but then he transitioned to daredevil
and he also became a Big Punisher
villain originally he started out is you
know more of a comical mob type
character when Frank Miller took over in
the early 1980s he got super dark I mean
Frank Miller he makes everybody dark I
know I said they adapted Frank Miller's
Man Without Fear comic for the TV series
but he started writing daredevil way
before that in the 1980s Man Without
Fear didn't come till the early 90s the
really cool thing is is if you want to
dive deep into daredevil comics
especially Frank Miller's run like his
you know 10 or so years on daredevil you
can read it all for free on Marvel
unlimited Wilson Fisk started out as
this overweight child who
I got sidelined just because he was a
bit of an outcast like like a lot of
Marvel villains so he got used to acting
through other people that's what kind of
started him on the path to becoming a
crime boss he committed his first murder
by age 12 educated himself in politics
and economics to PhD level so he's super
smart self-taught and learned to become
a sumo warrior that's why he still looks
crazy fat but he's super strong it's
it's all muscle it just looks like he's
fat he didn't get the name kingpin till
he was a teenager and he became a mob
boss over time like he slowly took over
other mob bosses territories till he
became the biggest crime boss in New
York City so as you can see from Robert
Downey jr. licking his face Vincent
D'Onofrio gonna be playing kingpin on
the daredevil Netflix series I'm really
excited about this Vincent D'Onofrio
he's an amazing method actor so I'm
interested to hear what he does to get
into Wilson Fisk mindset fullmetal
kingpin one really awesome thing that
the TV series is doing that's a little
bit different from the comics is it's
telling the origin story of the kingpin
so even though it's called daredevil
it's as much about the kingpin as it is
about the daredevil character that's one
of the things I think TV does better
than movies in comics so like a lot of
times in the comics you'll see a
retelling of an origin story and inside
of that you'll have like a mini story
that'll tell the origin of whatever the
villain of the series is TV just by its
nature has a lot more time to tell each
character's stories so because they cast
such a big actor and they have 13 hours
to tell this story they're telling the
origin story of kingpin as they tell the
origin story of daredevil it just makes
for a much more rewarding conclusion
when we get to the finale you know he's
not just a regular old villain that the
hero has to defeat he's a really deep
characters that's been driven to crime
by circumstances in his life as you saw
in the trailer that gallery that he's in
is owned by his wife I don't want to
give any spoilers away if you haven't
read The Man Without Fear storyline but
she is critical to his character
development in this storyline that will
play out across the TV series so don't
worry if you haven't read the comic the
TV series will make it pretty easy to
follow I think a really good contrast
with the way daredevil is doing its
villain story is that it's like a like a
50/50 situation with hero story villain
story as opposed to like agents of
shield which is like 75 percent about
the hero
and 25% about the villains like you just
don't spend as much time with certain
characters so it's not quite as
rewarding when you get to the finale so
I think that if you really like villains
stories daredevil is gonna be a lot more
fun and they did say because it's
Netflix it's not Network television
they're not watering it down for general
audiences it's gonna be super dark and
gritty so if you like really dark crime
drama with a lot of violence you're
gonna have a lot of fun with this if you
do want to read some really cool
daredevil stories in the comics and you
have Marvel unlimited you could totally
read them for free so can't get Marvel
unlimited you should totally check out
Man Without Fear just because that's the
story they used for the TV series some
other really good ones are kingpin must
die that story lines started with issue
number 170 early Frank Miller daredevil
early 80s daredevil it's kind of like
kingpin in Japan which kind of reminds
me of Wolverine in Japan then there's
gang war which is the storyline that
happened right before that kingpin must
die also early Frank Miller kingpins
wife Vanessa is a big part of it
obviously on a TV series because she's a
big part of this story it's really good
because she gets an extra context into
what his relationship with his wife is
like and how it informs his character
fast forward to 2010 there was a run
called shadow land it was a
self-contained miniseries where kingpin
crossed over with spider-man Iron Fist
Luke Cage and Moon Knight is a great
story and it's also fun because a lot of
those characters gonna be inside
defenders not not Moon Knight though not
Moon Knight or spider-man a lot of you
guys have been asking and I don't know
if I made this clear or not but yes I am
doing videos for daredevil because
they're dumping all of the episodes all
13 on April 10th what I'm probably gonna
do is just post like a new video for
daredevil every couple days because it's
like the same weekend the game of
Thrones is premiering so I can't do like
13 videos in two days but be sure to
subscribe to get everything if you're
just finding me for the first time if
you're brand new here here's a really
big question for you guys which of the
movie characters do you want to see on
the TV series you know they have they
haven't confirmed any cameos outside of
the other Netflix characters I think
they're trying to keep it self-contained
but they shot most of daredevil before
they cast Luke Cage or Jessica Jones so
I'm not expecting a ton of cameos in
season 1 a daredevil season 2 is a whole
different story though which event
do you wanna see in Hell's Kitchen on
daredevil season two because there's
street-level heroes I'd mostly expect to
see like agents of shield characters or
like the non-powered Avengers like
Hawkeye or Black Widow Hawkeye is the
likely candidate there's also rumors
that he's gonna be on agents of shield
this year so really important date April
10th is when all the episodes are going
live probably at midnight so you should
be able to marathon all 13 if you want
to don't worry I won't be posting all 13
of my videos right away so you don't
have to worry about suppose or anything
if you're not gonna watch them like all
right at once well you guys wait for
that stuff to drop you can click here
for all of my daredevil videos for my
last trailer video bye explainer for the
man without for your storyline and you
can click here for my explainer video on
Scarlet Witch in the comics and the
movies and all my other Avengers videos
thank you so much for watching I'll see
you guys tonight
now it's all I'll do the thing
you